Everyone, please think of your biggest personal goal.
For real, you can take a second.
You've got to feel this to learn it.
Take a few seconds and think of your personal biggest goal, okay?
Imagine deciding right now that you're going to do it.
Imagine telling someone that you meet today what you're going to do.
Imagine their congratulations, and their high image of you.
Doesn't it feel good to say it out loud?
Don't you feel one step closer already, like it's already becoming part of your identity?
Well, bad news: you should have kept your mouth shut,...
...because that good feeling now will make you less likely to do it.
The repeated psychology tests have proven that telling someone your goal makes it less likely to happen.
Any time you have a goal, there are some steps that need to be done,...
...some work that needs to be done in order to achieve it.
Ideally you would not be satisfied until you'd actually done the work.
But when you tell someone your goal and they acknowledge it,...
...psychologists have found that it's called a "social reality."
The mind is kind of tricked into feeling that it's already done.
And then because you've felt that satisfaction,...
...you're less motivated to do the actual hard work necessary.